[Applaudissements]
mecheri merci d'être avec nous et touche
pas à mon père si c'est chaud mais en
tout cas ce qu'ils ont fait
[Applaudissements]
c'est ton anniversaire aujourd'hui
autre chose je t'offre un bon d'achat
pour là c'est pour moi c'est cadeau que
je te dis tu viendras ce que tu veux
chez tartine et chocolat
[Rires]
faudra juste que tu baisses apple
adresse
[Musique]
roux qui sera avec lausanne à sedan et
surplomb style est ce que tu vas faire
de ce que tu as fait le plein de trucs
je ne sais pas encore il ya plein
d'idées le rappelle très bien placé là
bas tu veux pas qu'on fasse non mais les
plus grands artistes canadiens genre sur
scène est tous avec toi qui présentait
tu chantais tout ceci serait chiant mais
j'aime bien je t'appelle tout de suite
la patravi sur la vie de ma mère je
l'appelle de tu te rends tu me demande
un truc alors je l'appelle de suite
j'appelle alexandra raid qui est la
patronne des divertissements et france
télé qui est extrêmement simple t elle
est jolie alors voilà ras-le-bol face au
prince tu peux considérer que c'est
alexandra ma chérie c'est cyril hanouna
show avec garou là
et bagarre j'ai pas si tu connais sa
chanson seul celui qui n'a jamais été
seul une fois dans sa vie
800 seul par rapport à france télé voilà
il avait plein de trucs là et là ils
sont au milieu du gué quoi tu auras donc
on a une idée je vais l'envoyer au
québec là il va partir de là il va faire
je te le dis des duos avec tous les
artistes québécois je te le dis tout de
suite on a déjà céline dion sa prime
time tu choisis france 3 france 4
non france 2 françois parce que france 4
on va pas d'avoir d'artistes est ce que
est ce que vous voilà autour de la table
il ya un truc voilà qui vous gène est ce
qu'un détail physique
voilà où qui vous plaît énormément ou
qui vous dégoûte quoi qu'il arrive il
pourra rien se passer
moi c'est les cicatrices trouvé le truc
le plus sexy voilà une énorme
[Rires]
est ce que vous vous si vous n'aviez
plus rien à perdre voilà comme fabry
qu'est ce que vous diriez plus rien à
perdre j'ai un casse d'une banque comme
bernard un casse mais votre parking de
voitures seront bientôt je vais sortir
non je vous donne la réponse et vous me
donnez là je sais que vous l'attendez
tous les soirs deux fois par jour
combien de fois par jour vous appelez
votre banquier à moi j'appelle mon
banquier je sais pas pourquoi vous avez
quelqu'un qui à peine à vous c'est
combien de fois par jour votre banquier
vous appelle en outre à la paix tout
sinon oui de rock dans notre de rock mon
ami je mange je mouille le mec moi c'est
has been fans
[Musique]
[Rires]
dwan et phil ou de patrick et moi
lequel des deux paye le mieux à la
pratique
lequel des deux est le plus le plus de
mauvaise foi non
merci au nom je suis champion naba nord
annonce mais bon je suis non mais tu as
battu là
[Applaudissements]
de te la roue de la manne de l'ouest à
recevoir de la recevoir approché
orthophoniste
un petit chat merci et un petit pot de
mayotte ont découlé
[Musique]
m
b
versez les conférences
va les accompagner
mieux
c'est pas possible normal